[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I am NOT somebody who
believes in mandatory memorials to pain
the phrase never forget has always
troubled me not that we should not
remember but that to not let the grief
soften with time is to punish ourselves
and to embittered lives once six or
seven years ago I got through half the
day off social media and without the
television or the computer on and I was
startled that I had not noticed that it
was the anniversary and behind that
emotion of regret almost a sense of
having betrayed somebody I was a little
relieved that the clenched mixture fear
and sadness that marked the earliest of
the commemorations had relaxed its grip
on me and I hoped on others the
militarization of the memory the way so
many have exploited it and Exploited
still for their own purposes and the
politicizing of it that still angers me
but to me sitting here recording this in
the New World Trade Center thinking of
the previous one in which I worked in my
20s thinking of my college classmates a
man mcenany and Mike Tanner in building
one and my friend Dave authorities
brother Jim and thinking of Tom pecker
Ellie who was my cameraman at Fox Sports
and who was on flight 11 and a hockey
acquaintance named garnet ace Bailey who
was on flight 175 and Barbara Olson who
I had known when she was a frequent
guest the first time I was on MSNBC who
was on flight 77 thinking of them and
thinking of walking the streets of this
city covering that horrible day with
Times Square terrifyingly quiet at six
o'clock at night and the city
frightening Lee hushed four months
afterwards thinking of the wail of
sirens I heard at 11 o'clock this
morning
and how the sounds of sirens will always
be different on the same day every year
thinking of all of them and all of that
not all day but a part of every day the
calendar comes around to this day I do
have this one question how could the man
we are forced to call
all the President of the United States
who lives on Twitter who might no longer
exist if Twitter somehow vanished
tomorrow
how could he have not sent a tweet at
8:46 this morning or at 9:03
we're 937 or 959 or 1003 or 1028 how do
you not send out a tweet the morning of
9/11 how do you not send out a tweet the
morning of 9/11 on your first 9/11 in
office how when you have a social media
director who can and who has tweeted for
you do you not send out a tweet the
morning of 9/11 of course as the
Bloomberg television correspondent David
Gura reported Trump did talk the morning
of 9/11 he kept speaking at the Pentagon
as the 958 and 1003 moments of silence
had already begun but back to this
simpler issue how when given the manner
in which demographics change 9/11 has
long since replaced the Kennedy
assassination or the Challenger
explosion or anything else as the
life-changing moment in the psyche of
the average American and how social
media has replaced television and
everything else as the means of
conveying and commemorating things like
that how did Trump not send out a tweet
on the morning of 9/11 how could it have
waited for him until 2:00 in the
afternoon
this man tweets constantly promotes
books by disgraced sheriff's promotes
himself on Twitter threatens an FBI
director he fired on Twitter threatens
North Korea on Twitter is still tweeting
insults and retweeting mindless memes
about his opponent in an election that
in eight weeks will be a year ago an
election that is receding into history
he has two accounts and no matter how
reportedly bloated with fake followers
and BOTS they might be he can use them
to have direct access to 58 million
followers a potential audience that
Dwarfs whatever total he might have
reached on the anniversary on television
and he didn't tweet on the morning of
9/11 when they say never forget this is
what they're talking about shame on you